-Now, let's get to the news.
President Biden has reportedly
been telling aides
in private
that he no longer recognizes
the Republican party
and views them
as an existential threat
to democracy.
Oh, good, you're all caught up.
This is like when you watch
three episodes of a show
and you have to wait for
your partner to watch them
before you can move
to Episode 4.
"I hope I can
remember what's going on.
It's been like a year."
President Biden
spoke today in Buffalo
and called on Congress
to pass new gun-control laws.
Also today,
a tree fell in the forest.
In a new interview,
Dr. Anthony Fauci criticized
the Trump administration's
handling of
the coronavirus pandemic and
said it "wasn't optimal,"
which is kind of
like saying
the Hindenburg
experienced a flight delay.
In a new interview,
Supreme Court justice designate
Ketanji Brown Jackson
said the reality show
"Survivor"
is the best show ever.
Well, at least you're prepared
for votes to not go your way.
Sweden announced yesterday
it will apply to join NATO.
Wow! First Finland, now Sweden.
It seems like every day,
we're learning about another
country we could have sworn
was already in NATO.
The CDC this week advised
domestic travelers
to get tested
for the coronavirus
no more than
three days before their trip.
Incidentally,
three days before the trip
is also when your dad thinks
you should get to the airport.
"'Cause there might be traffic!
I'm not crazy.
There's been traffic before."
McDonald's announced yesterday
it would completely exit
the Russian market,
and that's not the only way
they're showing
their support for Ukraine.
[ Audience groans ]
Surprised. I don't know why
that one was the one.
Are you upset that, like --
that Grimace got painted?
Do you guys know
he's supposed to be a taste bud?
I just found out.
It's [bleep] disgusting,
but there you go.
I'm just thrown.
Police in Washington state
over the weekend said
that they had obtained video
of an Arby's manager
urinating into the
restaurant's milkshake machine.
The manager did that?
Come on, man.
You got to learn to delegate.
I don't think there's been
a single piece of good news
in tonight's monologue.
And I know you were bummed out
by Grimace,
but I got some good news.
People are pissing
in the Arby's machines.
According to the latest numbers,
the new 28-step staircase
that opened yesterday
at the Times Square
subway station cost $30 million.
Well, at least they finally
addressed the complaint
that no one had
about the subway.
"I don't mind the delays.
I just wish
the steps were fancier.
I liked the rats.
I just want new steps."
And, finally, it was announced
yesterday that
"The Masked Singer" will return
for an eighth season,
because they need somewhere
to put all the people
too embarrassing for
"Dancing with the Stars."
♪♪
President Biden
spoke yesterday in Buffalo
and called for
an end to white supremacy.
Well, good luck with that.
You've been in Washington
a year and a half,
and so far,
the only thing Congress
has gotten rid of
is Daylight Saving Time.
[ As Biden ]
Now that we took care of that,
move on to white supremacy.
We crushed Daylight Saving Time.
I mean..."
[ Normal voice ]
President Biden, yesterday,
warned that democracy
is in danger.
Even scarier, in a ransom note.
Former president Trump
recently announced
he is writing a book titled
"The Crime of the Century"
about the alleged voter fraud
in the
2020 presidential election.
Look for it in your bookstore's
Tantrum section.
Pennsylvania Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman
won last night's
Democratic Senate primary.
Pretty impressive for a guy
who looks like
a character from
"Mike Tyson's Punch-Out!!"
He'll now go on to face
Soda Popinski in the general.
North Carolina Representative
Madison Cawthorn, last night,
lost his Republican primary.
Hopefully he will
learn his lesson.
Next time you get invited to
a cocaine orgy, just go.
British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
recently called for Britons
to return to work in person
and said that his experience
working from home
included walking
to the fridge and
"hacking off a
small piece of cheese,"
then forgetting what he's doing.
Well, if it helps,
you're supposed to be serving
as prime minister.
Seems like that job
is big enough that
a little piece of cheese
shouldn't throw you off it.
In a recent interview,
Labor Secretary and former
Boston mayor Marty Walsh
said that Dunkin' Donuts
tasted different
on a recent trip to South Korea.
Said Biden, "You know that's not
why we sent you, right?"
"Here's the report on
the Dunkins."
According to a new poll,
1 in 3 Americans say that
the coronavirus pandemic
is over.
Unfortunately, he's sitting
between the other two.
"Great.
Between a couple of sheep."
Archaeologists in Laos
recently discovered
an ancient tooth,
thought to have belonged to
an extinct human species,
that was lodged in a cave wall.
Experts believed their
last words were, "Not...cake."
He -- He thought...
So, to work backwards,
he thought the wall was cake.
And then he bit it and died.
And, finally, the energy-drink
company Red Bull, last weekend,
held its world paper-airplane
championship,
while Four Loko launched its
first-annual Squid Games.
Former President George W. Bush
spoke about Russia last night
at an event in Dallas
and had quite the Freudian slip.
-The decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of Iraq --
I mean, of Ukraine.
[ Laughter ]
-Oof!
That's like your wife
asking if you're hungry
and saying, "I could cheat.
I mean, eat!"
[ Laughter ]
"I could eat with my mistress.
Aghh!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden yesterday
launched a program
that activates military aircraft
to import baby formula
from abroad.
Said the French, "White or red?"
[ Laughter ]
Health Secretary Xavier Becerra
tested positive yesterday
for the coronavirus.
Wow, the health secretary.
That's embarrassing.
That's like finding out
the transportation secretary
got hit by a train.
[ Laughter ]
He's fine. He's fine.
President Biden yesterday
formally endorsed
Finland and Sweden's application
to join NATO.
Though if it's anything
like his past endorsements,
it probably hurt
more than it helped.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the Secret Service
is currently providing
protection for 33 people
in the Biden administration
or family,
as opposed to to Trump,
where his administration
was his family.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk tweeted yesterday,
"Political attacks on me
will escalate dramatically
in coming months."
And based on
his previous predictions,
this can only mean
that political attacks on him
will stop completely.
[ Laughter ]
Health officials
in Massachusetts
announced yesterday
that they have identified
the first case of monkeypox
in the country.
But don't worry,
it can be easily cured
with, uh -- aw, baby formula!
Damn it!
[ Laughter ]
Son of a bitch!
The 75th Cannes Film Festival
began this week
and included
a live video message
from Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy.
But this is weird.
It was just,
"Please don't text
during the movie."
[ Laughter ]
A 2-year-old boy in Texas
recently ordered
31 cheeseburgers from McDonald's
through the delivery app
DoorDash
while playing
with his mom's phone.
To be fair, in Texas,
That's just one button.
[ Cheers and laughter ]
And finally,
the makers of Hot Pockets
have unveiled a new line of
cheese and cold cut sandwiches
called Deliwiches
that can be eaten hot or cold,
as opposed to Hot Pockets,
which are always a mix of both.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.